the Joe Rogan experience I remember I
went on did you remember there was a
show called the best damn sports show
period it was like an old school sports
show yeah this is like mm something like
early to die when Thanh the shows like
Tom Arnold and I forget all the people
that were on it but anyway I was telling
them like I go the sports gonna be huge
I go it's a it's the most exciting sport
in the world and I think it's gonna be
as big as any other professional sport
they were just laughing in my face
they're like what are you talking about
cage fighting there's no [ __ ] way
that's ever gonna be popular yeah yeah
what's up Jimmy the account that
announced this back in September the
Henderson Liddell fight is a parody
account that people didn't catch on to
yeah
don't kid yourself Hector Lombard fought
last night oh yeah yeah yeah one
I thought about watching that it was
weird I only watch the ones that backs
on Beck Rollins oh yeah right yeah yeah
very not go champ
yeah she's killing in there she came to
train with us again she was one of the
first people who were at Alliance one of
the first girls so that was one of the
reasons I went out there and how'd you
wind up getting Alliance you were you in
New York I was in New York then I was in
North Carolina and then that stopped
working out like a bunch of weird stuff
happens so I had to find a gym that was
good for me but also had girls like it
like the thing though saying about like
training with women it's like after the
tecia Torres fight I was just like yeah
I was under estimating how strong this
girl could be in school in Mexico
it wasn't Mexico City I was I was there
for that fight I remember these girls
like that is crazy altitude yeah 7,000
feet prepared
walking up the stairs to go take a leak
this is [ __ ] high altitude and I did
the exact opposite of what you were
supposed to do so it's like you either
show up a month early or two days before
you fight right and I showed up ten days
before I fight I was like oh
in ten days and it was like that was
like right at the peak of like when you
really start feeling that altitude
sickness so I was messed up from the
altitude I was sick from the I forget
what they call it the month of
Montezuma's Revenge it was revenge yeah
I was sick from that I was oh my god I
was out wait the entire [ __ ] ten days
like literally like walking out 115 and
so and you can see it in my fight
pictures too like I looked like sunken
out like my old muy Thai photos you guys
were like you were stuck in the mud
because the Alex oh yeah and the reason
I was so pissed because like right
before we fought or when we weighed in
and did our little face off T just like
hey let's make some money tomorrow and I
was like oh yeah all right let's go
let's go I'm like yeah we're gonna
[ __ ] stand it bang everyone's gonna
be excited we're in Mexico they lebackes
it we're just gonna hit each other it is
you plug it takes you down like on the
ground and [ __ ] like a [ __ ] what
do you call it half guard yeah and I'm
just pissed I'm like come on man like
just [ __ ] do something at least you
know but yeah she hustled me with
[Applause]